have you been aching to play some of
your xbox 360 games on your xbox one
well Microsoft has announced three more
games are headed to the backwards
compatibility program and I'm going to
run you through all of them I'm Matt and
this is your backwards compatible
gamespot news update the xbox 360
versions of darksiders Darksiders 2 and
assassin's creed revelations are now
playable on xbox one all of these
backwards compatible games have
remastered versions already available on
the Xbox one but if you want to play the
originals in all their splendor now's
your chance they'll show up in your
library automatically if you already own
them digitally but if you want them
physically then just throw that disc
into your console once you're done with
that make sure to LIKE and subscribe so
you're the first to know when your
favorite Xbox 360 game comes to the
backwards compatibility program call of
duty black ops 2 is far and away the
most requested game for backwards
compatibility but there's still no word
on when or if it'll even head to the
program Xbox head Phil Spencer recently
said in a tweet that one of his most
anticipated games is on its way in the
next few weeks in addition to some other
good ones being in the pipeline he even
made a point in saying no comment about
black ops 2 we can't be sure if that
beloved shooter will make its way to the
Xbox one but if you need some high
adrenaline action while we wait in
anticipation check out our video in
which we show how to create awesome
power combos in Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]